- [Voiceover] Hello grammarians!
Today we're talking about another kind
of irregular plural noun,
and that is the foreign plural.
Those are words that are
borrowed into English
from some other language.
Words like fungus, or cactus,
or thesis, or criteria.
And these words come from Latin
and Greek, respectively,
but don't get the idea
that you need to learn
to be able to speak Latin or Greek
in order to speak English.
No, not at all.
But while some words that
got borrowed into English
have lost their language-specific plurals,
some have not.
Some have maintained those plurals.
And it kind of depends on which situation
you're using them in.
So, for example, in an informal context,
it would be perfectly acceptable
for you or me to say funguses, like that.
But if I was talking to a biologist,
she would probably say fungi
if she were talking about
them in a scientific context.
Just like it's okay in informal speech
to talk about cactuses.
You're driving along a road in Arizona,
you see a lot of cactuses.
But, again, if you studied
cactuses for a living,
you would probably call them cacti.
It's more precise, it's more formal.
If you like, it's more polite.
Now, my feeling is, that
as fungus and cactus
get more and more entrenched into English
eventually these formal
endings are going to fall away
and we're just gonna
have this regular plural.
But for now there are still
some pluralizing rules
for other languages that it helps to know.
So let's go through those.
So I made this little chart to go over
the six most common Latin
and Greek irregular plurals
that you're going to encounter in English.
So the first one is final -a to final -ae.
So you take a word like
larva in the singular,
which is like a little baby bug,
like an ant larva, or a caterpillar larva,
and the traditional irregular plural,
the Latin plural of that, is larvae, -ae.
But the regular plural
that will probably get
more popular over time is larvas.
But this is the first one, -a to -ae.
Larva to larvae.
Just like antenna becomes antennae.
Secondly the ending change
from final -us to final -i,
which we find in a word like
fungus, is the singular,
and then the irregular
plural of that is fungi.
And, as I said before,
there are some people
who use funguses, but
again, that regular plural
is more informal.
This next one is also Latin
and it's the change from
final -um to final -a.
So we take a word like
datum, which is a single unit
of data, so the plural of data,
so we change singular datum to plural data
and there is no accepted,
you wouldn't say the datas,
that is not an accepted regular plural.
I think what's going to
happen instead is that datum
is gonna fall away.
But, again, it hasn't really happened yet.
Not in a formal context, anyway.
This next one is also Latin,
and it's final -ex or final -ix
to final -ices.
So if you take a word
like index, or matrix,
the plural of that is
not indexes, but indices.
Indexes is, again, the
informal regular plural,
but indices is the more
formal irregular plural.
Likewise, matrices.
This one is Greek and it's the change
from final -is to final
-es, as in the word thesis
in the singular becoming
theses in the irregular plural.
The regular plural of
this I do not care for
because it is thesises, and
I think that sounds silly.
But thinking something
is silly is no reason
to stand athwart the tide
of linguistic change,
grumble grumble.
This last one is also Greek,
and it's the change from
singular -on to plural -a.
So we this word like
criterion, or phenomenon,
and in the plural it is
criteria or phenomena.
(singing) Do do do do do.
And as with datum, there isn't really
a regular plural form for criteria.
Nobody says criterions,
because the word criteria
is so much better known.
Anyway, so these are
six little ending rules,
but, like I said, you don't
need to learn Latin or Greek
in order to make sense of English.
But having these six
rules in your tool belt,
if you use them judiciously,
will probably come in handy.
But, for real, if you see
a word and you don't know
it's derivation, just trust your instincts
and give it a regular plural.
Just tack on an -s.
You know, the world's not gonna end,
not harm will come to you.
And if you're curious,
you can look it up later.
You can learn anything.
David out.